at least 60 people have been killed in
an airstrike by the Myanmar military in
the Northern kutchen State the victims
were at an event celebrating the
anniversary of the catch and ethnic
group's political Wing let's go straight
to Tony Chang who's in Bangkok for us
Tony what more do we know
we understand that this was a
celebration taking place at about 9 00
PM local time last night three Myanmar
Air Force jets
attacked what appeared to be a big
Festival several celebrated kachin
singers were on stage at the time we
understand they are included in the
fatalities
this took place in Kansas Village in
Parkin Township an area which is famous
for its Jade mining it's very difficult
to get precise information although the
number of fatalities has just been
confirmed to Al Jazeera by a former MP
who's in the area at the moment that
area has there been a lot of resistance
to the military coup
the kitchen Independence Army have been
fighting quite fiercely against them for
some time it's been closed off to the
internet that's why it's taking so long
for this information to filter are out
but I was on the border with Myanmar and
speaking to people about how the Myanmar
military is engaged in this conflict at
the moment and they say that in many of
these areas where they're fighting armed
ethnic groups the Myanmar military is
using these techniques where they have
spotter planes up in the air
particularly at night where people are
very scared to turn on lights because
those spotter planes call in anything
they see and that airstrikes or
artillery artillery strikes then follow
so while information is still coming in
about this it does certainly follow a
very disturbing pattern that we're
seeing from myanmar's military okay
thank you for that update Tony Chang
there for us in Bangkok